hi
uh the title of this talk is testing
distributions of future objects i'm don
iran and this is joint work with odette
goldberg
so in order to define the model that i
will be
talking about in this uh in this
presentation
i first want to go back to two standard
models of testing properties
so the first model is testing properties
of objects that can be represented as
strings so here
pi
denotes a property of strings that is a
subset of strings and the tested object
is a string x of length n
the algorithm can query x at any
location and get the value of that
location and is also given a distance
parameter epsilon what do we require for
the algorithm
after asking a small number of queries
it should decide uh whether x belongs to
the property house that has the property
or is epsilon 4
where epsilon 4 is measured according to
the normalized hamming distance
that is the fraction of indices on which
the strings on which the strings differ
the other
model for a testing property is
assessing properties of distributions so
here p will denote the property of
distributions the tested object is a
distribution d
the algorithm gets samples x distributed
according to d
and also it is given a distance
parameter epsilon
here after obtaining a small number of
samples the algorithm should decide if
the distribution belongs to the property
or is epsilon far where distance is the
total variation distance so an important
thing to note here is that when talking
about plot pieces of strings
the length n of strings is considered
large or else i could just read
read all all symbols in the string and
the case of distributions uh we think
that the number of domain elements
as being large but
each element is read at unit cost
and when both models uh the algorithm is
allowed a small constant failure
probability okay so now i'm ready to
define the model that we introduce and
work with and it is testing property
distributions over large strings so here
p also denotes a property of
distributions
and the distributions we're interested
in are over strings of length n
so it may be
the domain maybe 0 1 to the n or sigma
to the n for some for some alphabet
sigma the algorithm has access to
samples distributed according to d and
it is given parameter epsilon similarly
to the standard model but here each
element is a string of length n
and the access that the algorithm has to
the string doesn't read the entire
string but it can query x in any
location of its choice
as in the string testing model
and what do we require the algorithm
after asking us
a small number of queries in total so we
measure the total number of queries that
it performs it should decide if the
distribution has a property or is
epsilon far and as before it is allowed
a small constant failure probability
so an important thing here is what is
the notion of distance since we want to
take into account uh also distance
between strings between elements in the
domain
and hence uh the distance measure that
that we work with between distributions
is the earth moves distance under the
normalized hamming so let me say what
this means i'll give a definition and
then also give an example which i think
will clarify this
so for two distributions z1 and d2 over
the same domain again not zero one to
then or sigma to the n what we ask is
what the the measure of distance is how
much does it cost us to transform one
distribution to the other what do i mean
by this we uh we move weight from
elements in one distribution to the
other and
we pay when we move some weight we pay
the weight that we move times that
normalized hamming distance between
between the strings so let's look at an
example suppose that d1 is uniform over
strings that start with the first bit
being zero d2 is uniform over string so
the first bit is is one
uh so i claimed that the distance
according to the earth movers under
hamming is just one over n and why is
that so in order to transform d1 to d2 i
can just match uh corresponding strings
here so what i mean a zero z to one z
the hammy the normalized hamming
distance between them is one over n and
i simply move all the weight i move the
weight of zero z to one z
it is the same in d1 and d2 and hence
the total
total cost that i pay here is just one
over n and note that that this differs
from the total variation distance where
uh the
the distance uh is uh one it's just they
have disjoint destroying support so here
the distance takes into account the
distance in of that between distribution
takes into account the distance between
strings
and i'm going to refer to this model as
distribution over huge object so the
acronym will be
doho and since we take into account both
the fact that we have the number of
domain elements uh that uh over which
the distribution is and the length of
the size of the elements
let me say start by a few observations
to get kind of into things about the
doho model so the first one is that um
it's not hard to verify that testing
properties of strings and just testing
probably distributions just as i uh
defined in the first the first slide are
special cases of doho so that's one
thing it's not only that we have it's a
hybrid of them but it also generalizes
both
the second observation is a simple one
but it's important to keep in mind that
the sample complexity in this new model
the doho model is upper bounded by the
sample complexity of testing uh the same
the same property of distributions in
the standard testing model
and this is simply because of the
relation between the distance measures
and the distance and the doh model is
upper bound by the distance in the
standard model and this also means that
the sample complexity may be smaller so
it's not only upper bounded it may be
strictly upper bounded
the next observation again also simple
is the query complexity of testing in
the doho model is always upper bounded
by the sam complexity times n and we can
always just query uh query x and all uh
on all all it says symbols and so we get
we get this bound now if we combine
observation two and three what we get is
that the query complexity in the domain
which is what we're interested in is
always upper bounded by the sample
complexity in the standard model times n
the point is so this is kind of our
basis but we are focused on getting much
lower query complexity
and the last observation i'd like to
mention
relates between the query complexity of
testing the doho model particular
properties that are related to the
string testing model so let me say what
i mean here
so suppose let pi be a property of
strings of length n so it's just some
set of strings right among all strings
of length n
and p sub pi will be the property of
distributions consisting of all
distributions whose support is a subset
of pi so for each subset here
and any distribution over it this i get
a distribution that belongs to this this
class of distributions
and so if i denote by uh the query
complexity of testing in this standard
string testing model by q sub pi
then the observation it's a bit more of
a claim since it requires uh some
a short proof the query complexity of
testing this property of distributions
in the doho model is uh roughly one over
epsilon factor times larger than the
query complexity of testing in the
corresponding property of strings okay
so we have several observations let's
now go into uh the the results that we
we have in
the model on top of these observations
so let's remember um by combining
observation two and three we have that
the query complexity and the doho model
which i'll denote by q sub p and epsilon
is upper bounded by n times the sample
complexity in the same uh property in
the standard
and what we asked as we said before are
the conditions under which we can do
much better so indeed there are
and uh so let me define the problem
the following notion
of properties of distributions being
closed under mapping what does it mean
it means that for every
distribution in this
class of distributions and for every
mapping every function f over the domain
we have that if we apply this function
to the distribution then we also remain
in the property so what do i mean by
applying the function to the
distribution and i mean that the
resulting distribution is is such that
for every
domain element uh y
that the the weight of the distribution
on y is the sum over the weights of the
elements that are mapped to it so once
again let's see an example that's always
helpful
so here uh we have a distribution these
are this is the histogram rather than
writing strings i just wrote
alphabet symbols i think that's simpler
so this is the first distribution and
now suppose that i apply a function what
do i mean i apply a map b to a then it
means that the weight according to the
resulting distribution of a is this the
weight that we had to be now suppose
that i map a c and f to d then i get the
sum over a
c and f and a c and f and so and so on
so this means uh this is a distribution
that we get and we want to be closed
under this transformation
so what does our first theorem say
presumes say that if p is closed under
mapping then the query complexity of
testing it is roughly the the sample
complexity of testing in the standard
model divided by one for epsilon up to
poly log n factors and here we take
epsilon over two so i'll talk more later
about this theorem also about its
implications
uh but before doing so um then we can
make it make a comment you might ask so
here i talked about all mappings now a
natural question is to look only under
mappings that are biject bijections in
which case i'll say that the property of
distribution is label invariant so it's
a
same definition except that we talk
about bijections so again let's look at
an example so what this is the same
distribution i start from so here i can
only um i can only apply some bijection
and this is the type of this is that
another distribution that i get it
should be um inside the property
so an interesting question is for which
label and various properties can we get
results similar to zero one so can we
generalize into what we have uh for cl
uh for properties that close under
mapping
um and i'll just mention that we have
some result for a variant of label in
labeling variant properties that is
based on self-correction i won't get
into the details you can see them in the
in the paper and the paper itself okay
so we have this theorem
um
which is a general one and now i want to
go into uh some other additional results
that we have that are
relate between
that talk about properties of
distributions that have been studied in
the past in the standard testing testing
model as we'll see serum one will play a
role
so uh the next theorem talks about
distributions with support size at most
m i don't know that that's p suit
less than or equal to m
and what we showed that the query
complexity of testing this property
is um is uh roughly order m times poly 1
one over epsilon
um and we also show that this is fairly
tight in terms of the dependence on
dependence on m
since the sample complexity the sample
complexity so of course the lower bound
on the query complexity
is
omega omega alpha m
and the next uh the next property that
we looked at which also has been
suddenly formed in the standard testing
model is um distributions that are m
grain what do i mean by m grey not only
is the support size bounded but actually
has its structure so that the weight
rate each x is some integer m sub x
divided uh divided by m here we also get
that that query complexity is the same
let's say of the same form and we also
have uh not as tight and lower bound but
still lower bound close to
close to linear on the sample complexity
the third uh theorem four which is the
third property that we looked at has
been studied in the past is that
distributions are uniform so here it's
even more restricted here really m of x
is just is one so it's uniform over some
set of size m
and here we also get the same type of
upper bound
and also we have a lower bound
which is similar but not precise to what
we had what we have here here it uh here
it was on the sample complexity um and
here it is on the on the query
complexity
and uh and here this is this is this is
important to note that while since here
we have we have the lower bound is on
the sample complexity in both of these
here the lower bound is on the query
complexity so it is fairly tight but
what we know is that the sample
complexity of testing this property
being uniform of a set of size m even in
the standard model
rows like m to the two thirds so we
don't have this relation between the
sample complexion and the query
complexity that is just a factor of poly
one over epsilon here we do here uh we
don't we don't have we don't have this
relation so it's interesting it's
interesting um to note
so uh um so in terms of how we prove
these theorems uh all the upper bounds
built on theorem one
uh which i'll talk about clearly so
let's recall what was theorem one we
talked about in the previous previous
slide it says that if p is closed under
mapping then we have the relation
between the query complex and the sample
class the standard model is roughly a
factor of one over epsilon uh one over
epsilon uh larger there should be a
tilde tilde over here so if we look at
these results then it is clear here that
uh the having support size at most m
um uh clearly is uh property that's
closed under mapping because we by
mapping we can only decrease the support
also being m-grained is also
clearly closed under mapping because
when we apply any mapping we still get
an end grade but then you say just a
minute but
the uniform over a set is not closed
under under mapping so but this is
proved actually by relating between uh
uniformity and being m grain so you can
see this again in in the in the paper in
the paper itself
um so i'll talk uh about here one
but let me also mention that the lower
bounds here that we have here are kind
of by transporting transporting lower
bounds from the standard model and this
is something that i won't talk about um
don't talk about much
so these all of these results were for
testing properties of single
distributions and we have one more
result here that also about previously
studied properties of distribution but
pairs of distributions so theorem five
talks about having a pair of
distribution d1 and d2 over strings of
length n
the algorithm gets samples from both
from both of them and it gets query
access to these samples
and what we show is that if we want to
test whether they are identical or
epsilon far according to the doho model
then we can do it with poly one over
epsilon times something like m to the
two thirds where m is the support size
of the of the distributions and we have
uh fairly
lower bound in terms of uh the
dependence on the dependence on m and
the upper bound here is based on random
restrictions which is also an idea that
appears in the proof of theorem one
and the lower bound is adaptation of
work um
of valiant
okay so one more thing that before i
talk a little bit about theorem one um
let me just say that we also have a
third type of
type of results which are new properties
that arise naturally in doho
and these new properties have they're
kind of of the form that
the distributions are based on variance
of an unknown ideal object so what does
this mean so here i'll kind of give
quickly kind of
examples of what what do i mean so one
result is distributions over noisy
versions of an unknown strings so here
the ideal object is some fixed string
that is unknown and the distribution
that i want to test is noisy versions of
this string and another result in which
again the ideal object is some string
and the distributions are cyclic ships
off of this
of this string so these are kind of new
properties that are kind of come up
naturally in the doho model
so now what i want to in the time that
remains i want to talk a little bit
about the proof idea of theorem 1 so
let's recall what theorem 1 says
theorem 1 says and here i remove the
subscript
p to make things a little easier to read
we said that if p is closed under
mapping then the query complexity is
roughly the sample complexity in the
standard model times one over epsilon
and again what does it mean to be closed
under mapping so i wrote i wrote i wrote
it here in case you you forgot that by
now
okay so let's let's see what i can say
about what is the proof idea
and i'll talk here about uh the domain
being zero one to the n it can apply to
other uh other other domains so uh if i
have a distribution d over zero one to
the n and a subset j i will denote by uh
d sub j the distribution that defined by
restricting d to j and concatenating
with zero to the n minus the the size of
j
so that the distribution that i get is
also over 01 to the n once again an
example to make things clear so suppose
that this is my distribution so um the
uh it's over strings are like three
then the the weight of the distribution
overall for each of the strings that
starts with zero is one over twelve over
each of the strings that start with one
is one over six
okay and say j is uh j is what i
restrict the subset of indices i just
stick to it's just one so it means that
d that the resulting distribution um i
sum over here i have four times one over
uh 12 so i get one third here i have 4
times 1 over 6 i get 2 3. so the
distribution is over 2 strings
0 0 0 and 1 0 0 and this is this is the
notion of d sub j okay
now what is the first very simple
observation
since p is closed under mapping
and uh
if the distribution belongs to p
then when i do this restriction no
matter to any subset that i that i
restrict to i also get a distribution
that belongs to the property simply the
mapping is the one that you may that you
may that you may expect
okay so now we have this um and remember
we want to relate the query complexity
to the sample complexity in the standard
distribution testing model so i'll let t
be a standard testing and its sample
complexity is s substandard
and i want to use it to get a doho
tester which i'll denote by t prime what
will i do
so um i'll take the t prime what it will
do is it will take a sample of size and
the standard roughly a constant
constant
sorry that's a problem with um with a
mouse that jumps
so um
i take a sample of a constant times that
sample complexity in the standard with
with a
distant parameter here epsilon over two
i select i or t prime selects a random
subset of indices
uh of size that is one over epsilon
times logarithmic of the sample
complexity divided by epsilon
and now what it does it runs the
standard testing model on the
distribution d sub j so what does it
mean i use the selected sample from step
one
and when the standard tester asks me uh
uh queries on indices that belong to j
that i selected here
then
they are answered by squaring the sample
so i paid for that and and the index
outside of that is answered by zero
because right that is the definition
that we have here of the
for the distribution the subject okay
uh so first thing simple thing the query
complexity indeed is like the sample
complexity here this is this times t t
right is the size of the of the uh of
the subset j so again then we get really
remember this we get what we want uh in
terms of the query complexity so let's
turn to talk a little bit about the
correctness okay so here what i did i
just wrote this is the the theorem uh
this is the algorithm that we just
talked about what just talked about
before
so as we said before the easy thing is
that if d belongs to p right then that
we want t prime to accept it uh with
high probability
um or with probability one if we have if
t is uh the original tester is has one
sided error then because v sub j belongs
to p correctness follows from that of t
right so this is this is the easy part
now let's go to that
to the other the other direction
so let's consider a distribution d that
is epsilon far from p okay so what does
this mean it means that if we could run
t like the standard testing on the
sample no no projection to j it should
reject with high probability
now
since p is closed under mappings and so
this means it's labeling variant right
we we defined this notion of labeling
variant before we can actually assume
without loss in generality that the
decision of the tester the standard
tester is based only on collision
numbers so once again an example of what
i mean by collisions suppose this is my
sample here
then we have these three
samples uh collide they're the same
these three collide so the collision
numbers i have uh one two-way collision
one three-way collision and one single
tone so this is the notion of collision
collision numbers
okay what would we have liked to prove
so uh we know that the the decision of t
i think is ran on the entire sample
than it would make decision according to
collisions so we would have liked to
prove that with high probability over a
choice of subset j the collisions of d
sub j
on s prime s prime is the number of
samples we take are similar to those of
um those of uh d
this is unfortunately not not quite
right uh when we perform when we take a
subset j then actually create these
new collisions rather what we do
we do the following for each subset j we
define in our analysis we define some d
prime it is kind of variant of d that
depends on j and what are what are the
properties we prove that with a high
probability over over the choice of j
what we have is that this special d
prime is epsilon 2 close to d which
means that it is epsilon 2 far from from
p right because d we're assuming
d is epsilon far from p
so
t would have to reject v prime if it
were given as prime samples that's the
first thing second thing that we prove
uh is that when we take d prime sub j on
s prime samples then indeed we get
collisions that are similar to those of
d prime
which would mean that t would reject
this distribution if it were given as
prime samples
and the third thing is that there's a
relation between so when i said it's a
variant that actually when we do the
restriction on on on j we get the same
distribution which means that so t would
reject the dj with high probability on s
prime samples
so this
this uh this uh gives us that the uh
that we the algorithm t prime will
indeed reject base with high probability
based on the correctness of t so the
main thing here of course is in defining
d prime and again this uh um
you may see and read this in the paper
itself
okay so let me just do a recap before i
finish
what
did we see here we define a new model
which we call doho for property testing
of distributions over long large strings
the algorithm gets query access to
sampled strings
and we present some general results i
talked about one but we have some more
abounding the query complexity the total
number of queries are performed under
certain conditions
and we give some almost type results for
specific properties of interest that
were previously studied in
distribution testing model both for
single distributions and for pairs
and we introduced new properties that
arise naturally in this model and study
them this i didn't talk about much but
you can you can read in the paper
okay
so
so thank you